this podcast is sponsored by surf shop
that's right surfshark are the
consistent sponsors of so many different
things on this channel so we need to
show them why we're so concerned we love
them right yeah they're great guys they
do VPN and we know what a virtual
private network is it keeps you in a
place where a your data's safe online
because you are Anonymous you can go in
certain cafes and certain public Wi-Fi
points put that on no one is getting
inside that firewall it could be up a
mountain in Madeira but that'll make
sense when you watch the public sure
yeah I mean if even if you want to go up
a mountain in Madeira and then you want
to Port yourself back to the UK that's a
smart thing to do I was wanting to watch
UK content couldn't watch any of the
iPlayer oh yeah VPN back in the UK
straight away and to add to that now
they've also got antivirus software do
you wrap it up before you go online
always and that's what virus software is
essentially 100 it's a condom for
yourself when you go on the internet
just shove it over your head well you'd
have to put a literal condom on it's
sort of just like a virtual thing yeah
exactly but the point is surfshark have
always been there for you and now
they're trying to protect you even
further than just your data and your
anonymity online so get out there and
get using it because it's 83 off three
months for free and it's if you use the
code Geordie at checkout yeah or the
link down in the description and the
code Geordie at checkout it's well worth
a look surfshark sponsor the podcast
they're great guys you know what people
love most when we just mention them say
go down there click the link get it and
on with the podcast enjoy
welcome back to the podcast Prince
William apparently he's been uh playing
away what and uh my Kate apparently
that's kind of what they use the whole
Megan thing for a distract from what's
going on oh Joe so it was trending on
Twitter prince prince of pegging because
apparently him and this other woman were
pegging doing some dirty [__] right well
that father like Sonos the modest thing
is is it was trending World like the
biggest trending topic on Twitter not a
mention in the papers not a mention of
it do you think there's a they can't
legally prove it maybe or you can
legally prove a lot of the stuff about
Megan but that was all over the very
good point which proves the level of
sway the royal family still have with
the media absolutely for anyone who
thinks that would you report that on BBC
News at 10 I suppose the worst place
would be for the BBC to break this story
BBC pegging am I right the memes were so
[__] funny by the way really there
was one meme of a
it was like an airplane uh three-seater
or a bus three seat uh with the you know
the uh you know the handle up and
someone had saved his seat with me oh my
god
um but yeah uh prince prince Wills is
um I can't believe I missed shagger I've
not seen this why do we protect the
Royals and why is it that we've managed
to find out about this why did Prince
William have his perfect life you've got
everything if you're Prince William you
have access to everything you can't
really do what you want yeah Harry's
called and he's gone [__] hell it's
great out here and Prince William's gone
what kind of stuff he went ass play he
went no way [__] it I'm going for it yes
I'll tell Kate we uh she can watch your
kids tonight I'm getting myself out
there with my leather chaps on I don't
know if you have to wear the leather
chaps but the PVC what it's underrated
PVC I've been watching it um no go on
Netflix show called bonding
I don't know if you've seen how much
time do you have I don't know I'm a
lonely guy for sure
um so what sort of thing are you
watching with that it's basically about
um
a woman who is a BDSM woman who's a
dominatrix right but it's a comedy show
and it's very watchable very but she
just dresses up in these outfits and
what sort of outfits are we talking here
like she's a she's a nurse she's a um
how'd you just have these to hand I just
you love [__] that's the best
Lawrence means that in a very literal
um people are [__] yeah insect
sexual sexual yeah yeah like that's your
problem I've been watching it like this
is actually weirdly entertaining and
funny so like but she's got a friend who
helps out as a like he's a gay guy but
he helps out with the dominatrix side
and he's a very funny guy but it's not
really about the sex it's the funny
moments within the sex right so where
people like piss themselves or someone
pisses on someone's face and what he's
struggling to piss so he starts singing
happy birthday and then at the end
they're like happy birthday okay and
it's like quite a funny moment like
there's just some mad [__] that happens
in it where um does it arouse you at all
only her outfits I think actually looks
very much nudity you know like Catwoman
in um Batman the original one she's the
Michelle Pfeiffer of bears on a serious
note though so is there much nude
uh no I can't really remember
interesting interesting yeah I think
English or American American I don't
think of Americans as into BDSM I feel
like they're very straight down the line
sex do you know what I mean those people
only [__] missionary Americans are
the biggest freaks going no no [__]
way have you watched Louis through come
on yeah but they're not sexually like
weirdly out there I feel like you could
definitely get more [__] weird [__] done
in you know
Thailand well Robin's out there right
now our cameraman so um we'll ask him
what I'm saying is though you know you
know when I watch Real BDSM stuff like
the real [__] okay like you know when
you watch how often does this happening
now you know when you watch like uh like
stuff where it's like a documentary and
it's always a dominatrix I mean at the
start you're going this is going to be
great this will be really [__] insane
it's not it's often sort of Dusty and a
bit dirty and like the men sort of
arriving there Ford focuses and go
you're right yeah so I just sort of pay
a couple hundred and then I go in and
men who want to be dominated generally
speaking it makes sense why Prince
William of all people would be one of
those people because powerful exactly
right and and apparently a lot of these
men who want to be like whatever
um tied up with all that all that [__]
it's about losing the power losing
control flipping the switch going
somewhere that you don't normally go
right I couldn't understand that this is
the thing and I think that there's an
issue in society where men n where
everyone goes men should be allowed to
be whatever they want men men should be
more expressive with their feelings but
the minute a man is seen to be in
anything feminine from personal
experience you're called a fog called
Gay called all of these things that I've
been called when well the damn thing
happens absolutely there's a real issue
there where people think oh yeah I'm Pro
men opening up and all of that but like
the minute anyone like everyone Snickers
like a school child and even I do as
well you know any anyone reading
anything sexual it's funny but when you
think about it
Williams a classic guy who would be into
something like that well just being
dominated in any way right from personal
experience from someone I've spoke to
um they said that people in that
industry they had been the Royals or no
no the BDSM industry the common people
who we want to live like common people
who are into it are like 40 year old
businessmen 50 year old businessmen who
are like [__] me their wife doesn't
shock them anymore they're stressed
about work they want to [__]
disappear into a dark [__] world that
didn't just black out almost become
someone else right and also they
probably have an idea of what they're
gonna do and the pegging maybe isn't the
start of it well I sort of go down a bit
of a well BDSM is a whole load of [__]
isn't it it's it's it's pissing on
someone it's whipping someone it's
[__] also right pegging sort of just
one element which is also interesting
because I I'd imagine they're also like
you said there's probably a lot of
people who just don't have the
relationship in their marriage to be
able to go I want to be X or Y well this
is part of the the the the show I was on
about was um there's a moment where like
they go to a house and the wife is she a
drop-in well she does a bit of
everything she's got her own dungeon and
all of that but she goes to houses yes
to these like and there's this like just
perfectly lovely couple and she's like
he wants me to do this to him and I
ain't gonna [__] do it so I've hired
you I'm gonna have a cup of tea and
you're gonna go up there and do whatever
he wants wow uh-huh we should imagine is
like you know all these things I bet you
it's not as I was gonna say yeah it's
way more common than you'd imagine yeah
like people basically just becoming
quite selfless and going listen I don't
want to do X I'm gonna let you do it
I've heard of uh like I I've heard of
hall passes like one of my mates who
when I was in the diving game shout out
to uh all the all the fans who love the
old diamonds his name was Lee actually
but he went he went away on holiday and
uh like a Thailand type holiday
obviously it was like sorry if I got me
seller a [__] while I'm out there
and and the way he sort of word he was
like ah she was fine with it saves her a
job and in my head does she not like
sucking dick I I don't know but like I
just found it a bit like that's a shame
that because to me sucking dick is one
of the greatest things a man can get but
also
um I personally think if you're in a
relationship you man or woman you want
to be meeting each other's needs Head On
And if and if you're not and he's having
to go to some [__] dominatrix it's
not ideal do you know what I mean how
much do you show in a relationship of
your side like you know if you're in a
if you're in a loving committed
relationship why isn't Kate pegging
William that's the real question that
was kind of where I was going with this
was like you know why isn't it that she
maybe she has I don't know maybe that's
part of it but why why do how much
should you show to the other person
should you show everything I think you
should certain things are they you know
is there ever a point that you should go
actually I'm not going to show that so
from personal experience like the more
you hide the the more likely the
relationship is to fail right it might
make sense if you're if you're feeling
like you have to hide a side of you from
that person that means you don't feel
like they'll be receptive to it and
therefore you're gonna hide that and
then eventually you're gonna go to
someone else who will be right and or
you'll find another way yeah I think men
and women have these because women are
under
pressure to be this perfect person who
maybe sometimes they're worried or if
I'm if he finds out I've done this but
like I know a lot of people in my life
who have supporting who have gone God
you know I've lied to boyfriends about
doing this that and the other because I
didn't want them thinking that I was
this person in my head I'm like well
that's who you are though right why why
pretend if this is what you're into and
if you're having a hide from someone
that side of you man or woman
you're not being the whole you not being
the truthful you and eventually this is
gonna that is like a a weed in the the
grass and then it's going to cause
issues down the road yeah you're not
being transparent in a relationship
where you need to be more trans and it's
like Chris Rock Says like whatever
you're into you need to partner into the
same [__] [__] right if you're an
alcoholic they've got to be an alcoholic
too right you know and you and with that
like you you can't half ask that that
has to be fully committed especially in
pegging yeah right yeah yeah not well I
suppose you go halfway but like just do
the tip um
it's like you could I suppose that's
where some people do go cool I'll just
go and find go to a prostitute do
whatever you want love you know I think
that's just a real shame when when
someone has that feeling about
sex with their partner you need to both
be into it like you said but when you're
both into it then you'll both get
something out of it and sometimes I'd
imagine some people just sort of suffer
through certain sexual scenarios he
likes it he likes [__] my feet but
you don't have a foot thing you needed
to find someone but but yeah but all but
you love him so you love doing it for
him and that's the point is whether it
be
a man who has a woman who has a very
weird sexual desire or vice versa it
doesn't matter you need to come like and
I know it's easy for me to say this and
I mean people might think I'm laboring
this but the reason I say it is because
whether it's sex or whether it's any
other element of your relationship
the more you
try and hide elements of your
personality early on and there'll be a
lot of people who listen to us who have
you know new relationships or early
release
stop trying to pretend like you are this
representative of you be you and if they
don't like that they're going to find
out who you are within the next 20
[__] years so you better be you now
so that if they don't like that then you
can cut the foot and [__] and get
someone who does like or they can give
you feedback on who you are and you
might actually get the honest feedback
about your personality that person might
say hey the way you do this actually
annoys me a little bit but I love the
rest of you and you might go actually
yeah that kind of annoyed me too or like
you know you the communication yeah and
that's partly why there's the breakdowns
in so many relationships is you're not
being truthful therefore you're not
communicating and therefore you're not
getting the best out of each other yeah
and BDSM is is an example of how that
happens when one person feels ashamed
that they have certain desires shame is
a very like I think that's more on the
women's part as well like when women
have been with a guy who's a [__]
Savage who's done all sorts and then you
get like there's some men out there
right now well no offense but they're
living in Dreamland thinking that
they're the best guy that this girl's
ever had and and
women always tell men that but the
reality is the chances are men there's a
guy who got there before you had a way
bigger dick who [__] her way better
than you are and she loves you anyway
but you could also be that guy so
remember hold that hope that you're that
big guy who's going right but maybe but
even if you want like don't mind don't
make her lie to you Embrace who she is
and embrace whatever that is to name it
although maybe that man likes the shame
of her lying to him and the shame that
he feels when she lies maybe maybe when
she says no baby you're the biggest dick
I've ever had he he goes tell me again
because he knows that she's lying and it
undermines his confidence sexually or to
the point where he comes and at that
point everyone's a winner everyone's a
winner aside from her no she's also a
winner because she knows what she's
doing I don't know you know what I'm
going you know what I'm going with it I
just yourself is what you're saying yeah
or be authentic I think that's one of
the mistakes I made when I was younger
what you weren't yourself well I was a
version of me but I was the best version
of me so here's the goal right and I
know this is basic but I hope someone
gets something from this because I
really have learned this about myself is
my goal when I was sat in front of a
pretty girl was
I need to get this [__] I'm being
honest I want her I fancy her so this is
my goal is to get that right when did he
get this so what I had to do with my
head was going what's the best road to
this what does she like what how how can
I make her laugh how can I you know but
and not in a cynical way it's just you
know when you admire a woman it's what
men do what my goal really should have
been was gone I need to find out if
we're [__] compatible and the only
way I can do that is by letting it all
hang out and be in the real me and if
she likes that then we've got a [__]
chance can I so can I start providing
you're talking about having a
relationship
men are going to be men and that's kind
of the point is I think some people
people enter relationships with
different expectations some women might
enter thinking oh he wants a
relationship some men might enter
thinking I just want to have sex here I
think you better be honest about that as
well right but also also because you can
probably get more out of it if you both
go I'm just here for the sex or I'm here
for a relationship or the halfway you're
building a different way right and
you'll you'll like because also in your
20s you don't or even in your late teens
you don't have to commit to being I only
want this kind of relationship for what
my life people seem to think that once
you've decided on the kind of
relationship you want therefore you cast
all other kinds of relationship out it's
like well I'm you know it's a bit like a
love Island when they go I'm just this
kind of person absolutely no but what
you I mean I don't watch Love Island but
well you know what I mean what you can't
find is some relationships that don't
work out they pivot and they end up
being something else that's actually
really good right like a friendship for
example that's amazing for the rest of
your life and that you'll always have
and always keep in contact with that
person but pegging friend you only get
that through just being the real you
right or being honest I think most
people most people are bullshitting
their Partners in some way shape or form
or a lot of people are not maybe it's
not most but and yeah that's just sort
of something that's been rolling around
in my head lately just to be authentic
in a relationship yeah and be authentic
in life like generally does cause some
issues in relationships though doesn't
it where if you are being authentic it's
sometimes especially if you're not
compatible in a good way and you don't
have a good way of solving it can cause
conflict in a relationship because
you're trying to be authentic I think
the telephone it tells you to have that
out and go you know what they're saying
[__] gonna work sometimes that's too
hard though isn't it you get what I mean
you're sitting in a perspective where
you are advocating for it and I respect
that but I think the other side is you
love someone and you want to keep it
together right or you want to keep it
together until after the family party on
the weekend do you know what I mean like
or like no we've got a date on Tuesday
yeah and there's men and women out there
who are in love with their other half or
or or damn near and love and and they're
going God I care so much about this
person I don't want to let that person
go but equally if we're being honest if
I'm being the real me in there being the
real them this wouldn't work I'm having
to accommodate them by being a fake
version of me to allow for this to carry
on because I you know let's say it's a
woman she knows if she's the real her
then he's gonna have a problem with that
right oh or vice versa so what would
have happened back in the day with
William the way that they would have
covered it up after the masses found out
about it was they would have said this
is actually a very Royal thing to do
so actually William wanting to get
[__] in the ass or whatever it is a
special thing yeah it's a special thing
that actually more you know he's
advocating for it in a sense and more
people should this is the other end of
his sword right yeah like and that is
that's a lion head do you know what I
mean gold yeah the diamond a gold
diamond lion head it's not plated that's
solid gold yeah it's not like one of
those butt plugs that you see those porn
stars but the shiny ending and also you
know when it's got the you know it's got
the sheath on it oh that's a whole lot
then oh yeah she can double hand that
she gets a little hammer on the end and
knocks it in very slowly and very gently
initially and then after a while she's
just shuffling because I've been
visualize William's face sort of
grimacing as each inch now further I
think it was covered and you were
thinking earlier about the hilarity of
it and that's of William's call on being
penetrated penetrated by a giant sword
so the point with that is and I'm not
saying it's happened I'm just saying if
it did happen
all sorts well I can't speculate but
they probably Slaughter animals in that
as well back in in the bedroom yeah she
probably chops the [__] sheep's head
off of The Sword and then shoves it up
his ass not the head the sword right I
mean either
um the point is though back in the day
everyone would have gone the King has
done this we must also Peg and everyone
would have been doing it and I feel like
nowadays we should almost take a leaf
out of the middle aged book you know if
if Henry got a divorce everyone else was
able to go and get a divorce if Prince
William pegs someone or someone gets is
pegging Prince William we should also
take his leads and build the Peg and be
able to no well you know we should also
look in our own relationships and go is
pegging if pegging is good for enough
for the Royals these people who are
Elite is it good enough for the everyday
man Brian let them pay let them Peg Let
My People pegs why people Peg they
pegged last week and then he won't feel
shame anymore no because everyone's back
he's a trendsetter exactly he's the Kim
Kardashian have they've been the
victorians they've been the Elizabethan
era this will be the maybe William needs
to give me a call I can sort of help
navigate yeah yeah listen William this
is just come out there's going to be a
lot of uh banter I'm gonna set you up
with a guy Stephen tries he'll make this
blower real quick absolutely all you
need to do is a royal news your hair is
getting [__] long I know really long
whenever I have a kid I grow it out
that's actually reason I mentioned it
because that's quite quite high on the
list of what people want to hear about
really you have again yet again Lawrence
McKenna call him daddy advice
impregnated a beautiful woman well done
thanks I do see it as somewhat of one of
my greatest achievements in life yeah
well at least you can do something right
yeah true yeah I can organize something
around here we're very happy although
I've heard she did most of the work
that's literally she's done most of the
work and growing that's a small child we
knew it was a boy the first time we
don't know what it is this time oh
surprise oh I've got a feeling what's
the feeling that I think it's a girl
really yeah
am I Bobby just because you had one last
time you're gonna feel no but like you
know that she behaving different yeah
like just she's a bit more relaxed this
time like a bit more just like yeah
let's just chill out just chill relax
and she looks a bit different and like
acts just slightly differently I think
it's a girl I just got this feeling
every time you know you can just look at
someone and go that's a girl but
everyone else goes boy either way as
long as it's healthier that's what oh
she always says so I was I think it's a
girl and then I'll try and like bet with
other people are you feeling any
different now because you're getting a
bit of a clan together here are you
feeling like oh this is not referred to
this as a clan
yeah it's a family now it's got more of
a family thing yeah right yeah I mean my
son's two and like you're really gonna
have a lot going on though I mean yeah
he's a little rambunctious kid
rambunctious is a great way of putting
yeah he runs around he's excitable he's
intelligent he's a very smart kid got
himself a scooter as well well there you
go then you can get for me to be yeah I
I said to him we can get to work easily
now son he's really he's a smart kid
he's uh smarter than me yeah he's lovely
we had a lovely family whole day with
him but it's a great time his first sort
of real Trip Away where we're not you
know we went to Costco last year but
this year we went around like a family
family holiday well yeah but he's a
little bit more able to take things in
though definitely like he's not just
sort of going oh yeah look at that he
looks more like he gets in the front
seat with the taxi drivers on your left
right this guy engages people more than
I engage with people like he wants to
talk to absolutely everyone especially
women and I just put it this way he
loves a woman with a tan but like he's
old mountain no but I mean like with a
real town oh really like he he will
approach anyone out on the street who is
just more time than anyone who's like
you know Irish right okay yeah so he
will never approach someone of like as
like clearly he doesn't look if you're
watching and you're a woman who's pale
you don't need to worry about this no
absolutely he doesn't like pale [__]
no I mean that's actually the way of
your first time at home the other day he
comforted a child in the middle of the
park who was just upset neither of us
knew why but he just went over sat down
next to them and just went and then
looked at me like am I doing it right
and I was like in a way but also that
kid might have monkey pox so stop
touching other kids yeah all right put a
mask on anyway I'm excited and you know
so tell me about the holiday
what was that like because you said you
had a couple of good stories I've got
some good stories from the holiday we
went to Madeira let me set the scene
Madeira beautiful island just off the
well not just off the coast but closest
to
Africa the west coast of it's not
necessarily what I was expecting you to
see when you saw my whole day what did
you no well you're like I'm going on a
family holiday
and I was like where you going you're
like it's near Africa I'm like two years
old well he loves it was he doing Safari
I mean I'd love to go on a safari yeah I
mean just give them a few years right
yeah he's got to be old enough as I
found out off of the lion whisper a
podcast that nobody watched
um no it was a difficult one for me I
love Lions I thought people would be
interested no I didn't understand why no
one was more interested but I do I don't
care why though there's no way that that
podcast got into the sub boxes
that's the one they choose to Shadow ban
I do think that they're highly
supportive at YouTube of uh lions in
captivity they were annoyed by what you
were saying yeah yeah the point is is
animals are triggered by
um little kids it turns out I didn't
realize sorry to interrupt
Madeira beautiful island where Cristiano
Ronaldo comes from oh yeah I forgot
about that yeah a lot of people with the
same demeanor as Cristiano Ronaldo
basically yeah yeah I think a lot of the
people on this island uh either love
tourists or hate tourists we stayed in
some beautiful hotels so we stayed in
like a quiet little hotel for a couple
of days built into the side of a
mountain why do you do that a lot you
stay in hotels no but you you do
multiple hotels right on trips I sort of
with me I go on a holiday and I just sit
I get one [__] hotel with one [__]
pool and I sit by that pool yeah with
you I think they've been a small gorilla
in stuff yeah you did that thing you
know what male gorillas they sit there
and they just go balls out yep that's
basically what I do I don't uh whereas
you you look at a Holiday like an
adventure you're like let's get multiple
hotels it's like you can't even unpack
your [__] suitcase and before you
know it you're packing again you're
going to the hotel sure that would drive
me mad does your missus not get
frustrated by you it bit me a little on
this holiday it's bitten me well there
you go though it's ironic that I would
point that out and all of a sudden my
level of Common Sense is applicable to
your I wouldn't say common sense to say
to stay at one hotel
no no no no no that's pretty normal no
but I get what you're saying how long
were you away for going two weeks 11
days all right the point is we we went
to the first hotel it was a Savoy we're
talking like you know they call you Sir
and Madame and you know it's pretty nice
place beautiful pools built into the
side of a mountain obviously my wife is
eight months pregnant at the time so she
just goes I'll chill out by the pool
with the kid and if you want to go out
and have any Adventure days or anything
you go get on it and if I can't say this
yeah being a woman who is quite slender
naturally yeah you can't mistake the
fact that she's pregnant no absolutely
you know some women are a bigger built
shall we say and and a pregnancy it's
really like she looks the same but it's
just like someone
right on the belly button right yeah
yeah it's pretty incredible
yeah you're weird because so so um so
she goes sits by the pool in what is
currently a very trendy hot pink bikini
because I think it's trendy this season
yeah Barbie you posted a picture of of
that we've had that experience
um a lot of perverted manner well I mean
it's it's the female form what do you
think about this because yeah like it's
sort of like um we had this discussion
because obviously we posted the photo
this thought or with her being by the
pool in a beautiful setting and wearing
very little clothing to be fair it was
something that you might see in like uh
one of those uh pregnancy magazines and
if you want to commission me I mean I
was sort of immediately I was like oh
this is this is a beautiful moment but
someone some of these
are funds and I use that term loosely
perfect we'll comment certain things
what kind of things have you been wasn't
so much the comments as kind of men very
much directly thinking that the DMS were
sort of a place to go you look oh like
pregnancy is really hot to me that sort
of thing which I'll do like do you have
a normally fans type shirt yeah I think
so because I also think the standard
expectation of kind of a mid-level to
low level influencer like me is that
we're so desperate for cash that we must
have an only fans right
um yeah and you know and times are hard
sometimes but not to the point they
should no they should what if you're on
Instagram you see how many brand deals
you do you're not hard up absolutely
every other [__] video well every
video actually yeah so it turns out that
a lot of men are drawn towards pregnancy
I think it's the bigger boobs and stuff
like that that comes with it okay so
there's a lot of benefits to pregnancy
right like there's bigger boobs
obviously if well is that a benefit you
know you're just seeing something
beautiful
grow and so you feel a lot more bonded
to your partner I think bondage but
awesome well yeah oh I think naturally
there is a satisfaction to pregnancy
because you go I did that in a way
you can't help but step back and
appreciate your work but what I mean by
that is what I mean how much we've
changed over the years no no but what I
mean by that is what I mean by that is
there is like an innate sense of
oh right like that you know this isn't
this is real I do feel a little like um
when you're speaking here I'm getting a
little more cavemani vibes from the
McKenna like a little animalistic is
what I mean like right the base level
yeah like at A Primitive the Primitive
side of our brain which is still there
as much as we're civilizing don't deny
it you can't deny instincts and feelings
that you're that you're just going to
have when you're creating a family and
also that I'm proud of I did that no not
not in a like a crude sense but in a
sense of like it's it's the you know you
found someone you care enough about to
have a kid with them and but the point
is uh you end up feeling really really
attracted towards your partner because
obviously naturally you're bonded a lot
of men oh really do you know I think
though I've seen this a lot in um in the
media I was like uh stories about how
pregnancy
can derail a sex life because some men
look at their women and and they feel
like they're scared to touch them in
case they do something to hurt the baby
or sure and also let's not kid ourselves
like not every pregnancy looks like what
you're experiencing I've had and I get
that some people have incredibly
difficult pregnancies well I just I just
mean some people eat a lot more yeah you
know and there isn't McDonald's just
around the corner well no but like you
know you know you're a fortunate man
let's just leave it at that but it
happened so far but some pregnancies you
know they they spiral right you know
some some women and you know who you are
out there some of you women out there
you'll love the sweets sure you'll love
the chocolate you love that okay and
some women think now I can put my feet
up I don't have to try anymore right
I've got him let's go to work let's go
to work let's go uh any Greg's any
McDonald's yeah some bodies though just
convert fat in different ways so oh
Genetically speaking absolutely the way
your
um sort of weird talking about flu like
this but um flu snaps back do you know
what I mean you know touch wood yeah and
um obviously every pregnancy by what
I've been told by a couple of my mates
who've had multiple children they say it
gets harder for the women each time we
get a little does it a little harder
like I said about flu is like it's a flu
is a slender woman who just looks like
it's all baby but some women
that's what I would put this but they're
built in a different way and their body
sort of goes I think their body
basically goes chick tick pregnant well
some women you don't know they're
pregnant until about seven months in
let's just say that because the the baby
is sort of protected by a layer of
something else blubber no but I also
think that's down to background as well
because oh yeah because we've had chats
obviously with other people like Sumo or
something yeah in a way to pursue what
is your background but what I mean is
like there's there's some people who
don't show like culturally or no like
blood blood wise so we were speaking
some people who are Latino right and
they were like Yeah in our in our family
Latino people are just hot on there yeah
they are yeah they're just like
literally the best looking people in the
world yeah if you're like that's the
thing about being based in the UK you
don't see many like you you look you
look on social media and like you know
what your recommended pages and stuff
have certain things come up you and I
probably have very different recommended
Pages no but like in my head I'm like
why is all the best looking people in
Mexico and why do you just [__] off to
me go to Mexico nothing stopping you
from going places because out there I'd
be a delicacy honestly you would people
they'd look at me and like who's that
Viking man that's why that's partly what
I was thinking was like if you go to
these places no one over there has ever
experienced these kind of you know
Viking types I like it yeah and many
ways they go I didn't realize UFC was in
town this week so what what were they
saying sorry about uh they're pregnant
too uh so they were basically saying
that they they didn't show until much
later some people show quite early flu
seems to show very early isn't it it's
just like oh oh yeah right yeah a month
later there's just a little you go oh
what's that that little bubble there
yeah and she you know like she I think
some women also enjoy it more than
others so you know some people have a
terrible experience like months of
sickness and also now I get suggested
all these Instagram and you know tick
tocks that have been ripped off of tick
tock and put on Instagram where it's
like listing the top five things that
are a symptom of pregnancy that you
don't want and you're like why are you
pointing like that to music and then you
have to watch it and it's like piles and
like you know constipation and things
like that and I'm just like okay well I
haven't heard any of those I don't think
I'd cope very well with all of that flu
doesn't moan at all like she is you know
our relationship has grown to a point
where she moans zero about being
pregnant ever and well I think that's
pretty that's nice because it's a gift
that not everyone gets and there are
some women out there who do struggle
though right you know like to get
pregnant well yeah there's things like
um polycystic ovary yeah and another way
more common than you expect
endometriosis and stuff like that so
there's stuff out of reasons yeah
there's women out there who are really
struggling who such a weird thing that I
would come on to this but we're going to
go on a little detour just take a second
I was watching this [__] um crime
YouTube documentary thing okay right and
there was this woman who couldn't get
pregnant she used to go to this weekly
thing let's I can't remember what it was
but they were like a book club or a club
of some sort and she noticed this other
woman was pregnant and she was like yeah
me too
she was lying that's weird gets to the
point where it's like eight and a half
months pregnant there's a knot at the
door someone's uh the girl's selling a
puppy or something like that and
someone's made an arrangement to come
and collect the puppy she opens the door
it's the girl from the book club yeah
before she knows it she's [__]
cutting her belly up and reaching inside
pulling the baby out leaves the the
woman dead on the floor walks off with
the baby goes home now a fella who's
just been telling the whole time she's
pregnant and she's like oh I had the
baby he's [__] clueless right don't
know how how the [__] are they I know he
literally was exonerated though like he
was like uh found like completely
innocent in this is this guy not had any
like has he never turned like rolled
over in the night and gone
the name of the case was like womb
Raider I'm not even joking so bad right
but anyway stop branding things that
poor woman so her mother kit comes home
fans are like that and she literally
Rings up and she's like my daughter's
lady as if her stomach's exploded
there's no baby I don't know what's
happened so how did they find out that
the woman had done that did she admit to
doing that the feds were involved
immediately because it was such a dark
case that is really um like this is what
happened though like she'd been abused
and she couldn't have kids and she'd had
all sorts of issues but the point was is
she literally she was like oh I've just
been in the hospital the federally we
checked the records yeah the baby
survived and the baby now is still alive
with the dad
poor mother died I mean that is a
horrible [__] traumatic right that's
probably one of the weirdest boats ever
I'm gonna come back to this but I've
been watching a lot of dark crime stuff
when you say dark crime but you say it's
dark no but there's loads of YouTubers
who just tell stories about like are
they true no they're all they're all
true it's like you know how like there's
ASMR and like there's FIFA YouTube
there's like there's a group of like
true crimas basically true crime or dark
crime well true crime but it's it's this
one was a the guy at the start was like
if you're into some weird dog [__] this
is the one for you but in my head I was
like not really sure we should talk
about why not this well it's like this
is the one for you and I was like I'm
not celebrating that this happened no
well do you know what I mean oh God I'm
glad this happens for my entertainment
pause popcorn but there is an element of
my brain that's a bit like why am I
listening to this like this is going to
stick with me for the rest of the day
it's bad and longer and now everyone
else out there has to hear about it womb
reader you know there are people who
pause this video went out there in such
women is [__] mud in it that's kind
of what I've been thinking about though
over the last week a lot of freaky
people life makes people go a bit crazy
so the creation of life in pregnancy and
those kind of things sort of turns
people a little bit mad people obviously
and I feel terrible for people who can't
have kids there are some people who that
turns in a very dark way you know it can
really impact people because their whole
life dream is around that you almost get
like some sort of semi-god status when
you're pregnant in society do you know
what I mean like you really get held up
as like a oh protect this person because
I hear you had sex yeah and that's
essentially yeah it's like what Chris
Rock says even roaches have kids like
you're not you know this isn't um that
amazing in in the way that some people
make it out to be and it is amazing on a
personal level but not a macro and
that's it and I think that that's what
people forget isn't it is like who gives
a [__] it's your [__] life go and
live I think there's an ego side of
people where they they feel like they're
passing down their Essence into a child
and that's an extension of themselves
like standard I think my dad to be
honest with you there was a part of him
hence calling me Brian and him being
called Brian you know like
there was a lot a part of it was like
chip off the Yellow Block he's a bit of
me you know and I think there's a lot of
men who get that feeling as well of like
this is me leaving a piece of me
absolutely on this planet to carry on
how great I am yeah you know and it's
bollocks yeah in a way to me the the
idea should be like a little different
than that you're talking about like the
egoic drive that's the doing that the
ego side of it is bollock is yeah I
think on a futile having kids should be
about
a product of the relationship that you
have with the person because when you
start doing it for other reasons a
you're not in a team and and be you're
kind of condemning that kid having a lot
of [__] issues which we're also
finding is like another big issue yeah
like they're a lot when you don't do it
for the right reasons yeah and you know
what I don't know if there's ever the
perfect time to have kids some people
might come to a point where they feel
they're ready to have kids but there's
never a perfect time because you can
never be fully Brave there's definitely
bad times absolutely if you're if if if
if your age levels has teen right in it
uh bad choice unless you are in a very
solid Christian family where the
mortgage is fully paid keep doing the
anal just keep shoving it up the old ass
shove it up your ass yeah or at least
come in the ass right yeah finishing it
and we're not advocating for it we're
just saying and if it's back if you have
to although I think that's what a lot of
Christian men do okay we're getting back
to Madeira I do apologize because I took
this on another detour
all that Madeira it's great it's a
beautiful island multiple hotels nice
hotel but when we get there flu goes
right listen there's only a couple of
days left in the whole day I know
there's a couple of these day trips you
want to do like you want to do something
adventurous like you know that feels
adventurous oh so she's gonna allow you
to nip off there while she chills while
she chills this is so funny the way she
treats you like her son no no you didn't
realize that sure the way she was like
right I know you want to do this go on
get up there she was telling me for the
whole house make sure you're welcome and
see you I basically have booked this
tour and I got back and I went to the
hotel and I went listen I need some cash
to be able to pay the tour the next day
the guy goes listen we booked this Tour
all the time don't worry about it you
get to the tour bus and you just say I
just need to go to a cash machine on the
way and I'm like I don't really like
doing that can I go to a cash machine so
I go to a cash machine the cash machine
is out of money
[__] so I go to I actually walk to
another cash machine cash machine is
closed so I get up the next day and I go
to the spot where I'm meant to meet the
tour guides I'm waiting for 20 minutes
what I don't want to do is leave this
spot and go to another place to get to a
cash machine but I'm waiting for 20
minutes and the bus that is there to
pick me up is 20 minutes late people in
these countries though they're a bit
laissez-faire yeah they're right they're
not stressing out about being on time or
well you'd be surprised but the point is
right
I I don't go and get the money because I
think okay well this nice hotel has told
me it'll be fine don't worry about it I
call the place and I go listen I'm at
the place I'm worried I'm gonna miss the
tour and they're going oh don't worry
about it obviously the bus has got to go
around all these hotels and pick up all
these people you'll probably just be one
of the last on the list
so anyway the bus pulls up about 20
minutes after it's meant to pull up and
off Hops at the front a man who's no
taller than Rory so diminutive a short
amount yeah whips his cap off and he's
bald
glasses I could just tell there was
something a bit off about him
um he had the same demeanor to be honest
of my old flatmate with the gun oh
something's a little off so for those
who don't remember Lawrence had a
lunatic uh for a flatmate Once Upon a
Time maneuver from hell so anyway I go
over to him and I go uh hey hey I'm
Lawrence I'm here for the tour listen uh
got back late last night couldn't find
an open cash machine I had 25 Euros but
the tour was 45 Euros I know we're
getting a little spending on holiday but
it's lovely right I go I can give you
the 25 Euros now as like a you know I'm
taking them as a down payment and then
we'll just go to a cash machine and get
some more cash out and he was like no no
pay me all at once and I was like okay
fair enough all right all right fine so
anyway
we go and we the bus drives you a long
way because it's sounds like hell
already it's a minibus so it's about 12
to 15 people on it most of them quite
old I'll be honest and I looked and I
looked down at my brochure and I thought
some of you aren't going to make it
through this some of you will rest some
of you will die over us yeah exactly I
like it and you know most these people
at this point they're a little too big
for the small minibus seats so you sort
of have to like squeeze down through the
middle of the minibus god almighty only
the back seat is there so it's already
it's cast me as the guy who sits on the
back seat sort of the black sheep of the
family if you will halfway up the
mountain we get to a cash machine
brilliant the guilt's been building up
at the back everyone else has paid I'm
getting this for free not everyone else
are paid there was another blonde
middle-aged woman who hadn't paid anyway
we get out and I go over I put my like
I've got like a travel card that lets
you withdraw stuff this machine just
rejects it like it just won't take this
travel course
yeah have you got anything else no not
on me at this oh you didn't bring a
regular card no I've got a regular card
but I just thought well the travel card
surely will work oh right oh that was a
big [__] up on your part well not not a
massive [__] up but I'm like I mean it
but you're relying on some random ass
travel card being accepted everywhere
right what were you thinking no no so
here's my point is what I forgot was in
my bag I actually put my full wallet
right so anyway I go back to the guy and
I go listen I've got a travel card and
it doesn't work I you know is there
another cash bear in mind also this is a
cash machine halfway up a mountain this
guy's gonna be so [__] up so this guy
is [__] off right but at the same time
I'm on his bus and I can't get back
without that so and I know my intention
is to pay I'm not gonna he's looking for
a free ride up this mountain yeah
exactly why the [__] would I look for a
free ride up a mountain yeah do you want
to see the sights free of charge exactly
so anyway this guy looks at me and he
goes you're using it wrong bear in mind
there's got to be an element of customer
service here at this point I I was sort
of panicking in my mind because I was a
bit like I'm halfway at the moment half
of a mountain I've really [__] this
guy off and at that point I haven't
thought I've got the other wallet in my
bag I'll go and try that he looks at me
and I go why don't you come to the cash
machine and see because another woman's
used her card and come out and there was
money right maybe I'm doing it wrong
because it's in Portuguese so I was like
maybe I'm doing it wrong you just have
to show me so we go back over put it in
and we try every option you know where
you can convert from pounds to euros
Euros to pounds or that kind of thing
and the guys just look at me and he goes
oh you've you bought a you bought a car
this [__] and I'm like what I literally
look at him and I'm like does customer
service exist in the in this place right
he's exhaust rated at this point right
so I'm like listen uh when we get back
into town because we're staying in the
city there's loads of card machines
there that I know it works with so we'll
just go to that right and he's like yeah
fine okay so we get back on the bus and
the guy basically then starts to give a
little speech
right
no no
balance right not about Finance okay but
it's clear that it's the record of you
it's clear that it's directed at me it
starts off with like for those of you
who have paid fantastic great good to
have you on the bus and I'm like okay
brilliant and then he says everything in
French but he's clearly loving himself
like he's clearly a man with a bit of a
chip on his shoulder yeah I mean he
literally goes up a mountain every day
like there's not every day once a week
but so he refuses to do it any other day
but Tuesday so I was lucky enough to get
on this Tuesday tour right this man is a
real ego given his job is the most basic
job you're literally walking you're a
mountain goat we get up to what is like
a a weather station
just below the peak so that what we feel
is we've walked to the top of the
mountain I'm like this is genius
brilliant okay we'll do a short walk now
with all these old people get to the top
snap snap back we go brilliant okay the
guilt will only sit with me for a matter
of hours and you'll have the pictures
forever and these are great pictures so
I'm wandering around and he goes go in
there grab yourself some sandwiches and
stuff and some you got some drinks you
will need drinks and sandwiches and no
this is I've already got a cheese
sandwich in my bag and I bought some
cherries fantastic who doesn't want
cherries on a walk didn't have much
water though so I go in and I'll buy
some water with cash little do I know
old Hawkeye over there has cottoned onto
the fact that I've used cash to buy the
water oh no he's got cash right so ah so
I turn around to him doing this
at this point I haven't clocked this
because in my mind we've had this
interaction where I've gone listen I've
got 25 Euros here should you want it
it's yours and then I just go without
water this guy's looking at me he's
looking at me like
son of a [__] so anyway I I'm none the
wiser I'm like hey good to see how you
doing walk off this is where the
seething begins on the trip I go and ask
him a question he sort of just doesn't
he sort of goes I'll talk about that in
a little while so I'm like okay fair
enough his demeanor's really off like
but not just off with me off with
everyone in the group apart from the two
hot French girls well they're like they
weren't hot but they were attractive to
him in the middle of nowhere in the
middle of nowhere and Madeira and people
aren't ugly people but like you know
he's a 50 something year old they're
different as well yeah everyone loves a
bit of difference and also he can speak
of their French so he can sort of flex
his languages on them and you know you
can sort of see it made me mildly
uncomfortable do you like my bus it
wasn't even his bus but it made me
mildly uncomfortable to watch him
interacting with them because these
women are a bit like oh yeah okay great
okay cool old us man yeah thank you for
looking at my boobs I then realized I
come out in basketball shorts and a long
sleeve shirt just in case of game breaks
out if we get to the fourth quarter guys
then this is gonna go slam dunk on the
top of this mountainboard right but I
hadn't really bought walking shoes or
any of this [__] I just bought normal
Jordans in case you were wondering no
but you then get a context of the way
that my shoes look compared to the
professional rambling crew that it turns
out I'm with you know the little um
backpacks that have got straws that you
can oh sip for oh they were ready These
Guys these [__] are ready okay
this is like Sony Everest yeah I'm
looking around going I don't know I
thought you were just going for a little
John but a little acid eye and some of
the old people in the group but these
guys suddenly get very serious about
this all right and it's like listen guys
we're gonna have three mile three
kilometers that way two kilometers that
way there will be ladders on the way and
then two kilometers down three
kilometers to the finish I'm like well
it's like 12 kilometers but you're a
very fit guy but some of the old people
you will not make it you're gonna die on
the way Irish man who's come for three
days
so at this point some of the English
people in the group there's murmurs
amongst the English were you aware of
her were you yeah was this sold to you
in this way
boss right at the top we're gonna have a
look look afterwards there's a guy with
a [__] knee brace on over here I'm
I'm basically he's got a knee brace he
looks at me and he goes I don't think
I'll make it I was like I don't think
you will either buddy like but he's like
I'll try and I was like okay fair enough
but whose responsibility is he if [__]
goes wrongly no I mean well clearly not
little Baldi at the front yeah every man
from Sun at that point everyone's
gearing up I've got nothing I'm
literally just standing there and in my
shots but also I don't feel cold and I
don't feel in immediate danger that it's
gonna rain anytime soon I'm looking
around I'm going these guys are taking
this so [__] seriously you guys are
getting you guys are getting way too
into this but I'm a little bit worried
that maybe I'm not prepared for the walk
Andre has got a blue cap on
strides out like this guy is set in a
pace that even professional like
yourself uh you know uh mid-level
Walkers right don't you probably
couldn't keep up with this must be why
he only does it once a week yes
absolutely for the rest of it yeah so he
sets quite nice and who's he setting the
pace with that's right the French so the
English people left at the back right
and at this point I start to feel a
little Affinity with my fellow
countrymen oh yeah you are quite
nationalistic in a way I look around and
I see a lot of I see some old eyes
looking up stuff up the look goes
they're looking a little bit concerned
at this point okay so anyway I'm like
great well bond is a group and we'll
catch Andre up I'm the tallest in the
group by a long way so I'm like
I can see him don't worry we're all good
I look over the head he's not really
being majorly responsible by dividing
the group up yeah and it's at this point
I've sort of realized
Andre isn't your normal tour guide he
just wants to get the [__] top turn
around get the [__] back home absolutely
it is a very small path with drops on
either side of it all right my legs were
shaking a little bit when we went across
one or two of these bits because it was
quite slippy like it was it looked like
at any point some of the gravel could
just sort of come away and you just
you're a tall guy light body weight You
Know You're Made for This shirt
essentially absolutely these fat old
people must be like what the [__] were
we getting ourselves into a lot of them
complaining at this point all right I
see it here is my role Andre has let the
group down all right we've paid here for
and well some of us have yeah exactly
yeah I have the intention of pain right
you're earning you're keeping a
different way yeah yeah but also I'm
pissed off because I've come for a tour
and if I come on a tour I don't just
expect you to bus us there and then go
to follow for yourself but not only that
yeah I'm fending for myself but not only
that there is I mean literally mountain
lions must be not been around anywhere
surely yeah and and on either side it's
a shared there's a sheer drop and this
is I'm I'm there going I want a tour
there are people in the group going I
came for a tour I came to get talk I did
and we're watching other groups where
the tour guide is giving a lovely speech
at different points Andre's just he's
just giving speeches about people not
paying but he is he's so pissed at this
point at this point I think
Andre's gone somewhere else I'll
jokingly do another tour oh so you
decided to take the piss out of him so
Andres nowhere near within air shot of
us and I sort of every now and again go
anyway that's a little bit of Heather
there I don't know if you've noticed
that guys it's uh cool bit of history
about that but we'll never know a couple
of people are laughing like you know the
guy's sort of making up jokes with me
and there's another guy from Essex who's
sort of going no this is probably out of
order actually mate like we should get a
[__] tour here do you know what I
mean like we need a tour we're on the
side of the mountain I didn't come for
nothing and the Irish guy was annoyed
but he was so mild-mannered that he
wouldn't say it but he kept going yeah I
wasn't sold this at the front desk like
this you know anyway we start talking
about each other's lives and stuff the
Irish man being very affable lovely guy
he's he's laughing through the pain and
I turned it one time I've got real
respect for the fact you're just
carrying on with this weirdly and this
is what I realized you're a student
you're a [__] Lawrence I went alone on
this tour everyone else is with someone
the other couples I'm going where are
you from oh you're from Hungary and
you're from Essex right you just got
married where are you from okay so
that's cool so you guys met in Poland or
whatever right the Irish people very
iraffable and then they go where's your
wife from oh my wife's from Kosovo
originally she came over during the
course of war in 97 and blah blah blah
yeah uh and somehow we got into like
religion oh God
happened to mention that my wife's a
foreigner and a Muslim I don't hear a
peep out of the guy for the rest of the
tour and if at any point I try to
interact with him he just doesn't
acknowledge that I'm even there wow most
uh racists are better at hiding it yeah
I think his whole concentration was on
the knee at this point so this just
oozed out at that point he was pretty
angry though so I I sort of read that
and went okay I mentioned the Muslim
foreign thing won't mention that again
won't come back to you leave you alone
for a little while so anyway we get to
the first clearing which is beautiful
is amazing look we're in the middle of
all these mountains God's Splendor is in
front of us what has the Lord given us
this is incredible Alice splendor's in
front of us and I just shout Allah no so
I I I'm there yeah right I mean that's a
lovely way of putting it
I think um I think it's that at this
point I'm sitting down having my cheese
sandwich taking in the Splendor of the
scenario I kind of like I don't wanna
because the tour guide just keeps moving
on without telling people moving on so
I'm always keeping a little eye on him
across there's another guy who was a
tour guide immediately behind us having
a chat with him in hushed tones and
doing this
at me
it's so easy I'm like that's weird like
that's what they what can he possibly be
pointing to me for and then the small
guy starts walking over to me so I think
okay this is best to stand up for this
oh yeah I've got the cheese sandwich and
I've just finished it and so I'm sort of
like just dusting my hands off and he
comes over and he goes um
listen I've given you two opportunities
to pay now
if you don't pay here
you can leave the group a little weird
thing to say like you're gonna be two
opportunities to pay and really you've
given me one opportunity to pay because
I went to one cash but he has already
agreed to pee at the end yeah so you
can't change the rules now you're up the
[__] moment in my mind what do you
want me to do I have a decision to make
either I go back at him because he's
saying this like that far away from my
face like really getting in my face on
his tiptoes honest tips yeah like sort
of getting up and I sort of go
that's very weird because I've been to
one cash machine with you and that
didn't have any cash in you know you're
going to get the money and he goes and
my friend over there told me what you
said
you can leave the group and go ahead of
everyone else I went and that's weird
that sounds quite threatening to me and
he and he goes
oh and I'm like all right okay so I go
so you're threatening me on the side of
a mountain though is that is that what
this has come to like do you want me to
go to a cash literally I use your line I
was like do you want me to go to a cash
machine here what do you want me to do
so this guy
starts backing off and starts walking
away and just starts walking away from
me almost like
this guy and starts doing that in front
of the whole he starts going this guy
and I'm like no no you want to do stuff
in hush tones you might as well do it in
front of everyone then what did you just
say and he went well it doesn't matter
what I said I think it does you're a
tour guide here you're meant to be
guiding us up the side of a [__]
Mountain what is it what have you got to
say and he was like we don't need to do
this we don't need to do this so anyway
I turned to the other tour guide and I
go what did you say to him and he goes
like it doesn't matter just know US tour
guides we stick together and I was like
I forgot about the Brotherhood of tour
guide I forgot that I was working with
star commands well it's ironic that you
lost it together because this [__] has
left us behind for the majority of this
[__] trip it was exactly what I said
I literally went you did more of a tour
than this guy did for me I heard more
from your tour than the other guy and
the guy is like well you know we you're
like you know we we've got to stick
together with this kind of stuff they're
not smart people are there but it
annoyed me every week they're going up
and down a [__] Mountain saying the
same [__] by the way you don't have to
navigate this it's all one part I mean
it's quite clearly yeah you could have
dropped me off in a taxi how am I gonna
to guide people through the treacherous
terrain right it's one [__] road it's
one road there was one point where it
forked and it was quite clear even to my
untrained hiking mind that we don't go
down the bit where the steps aren't
quite right right we go back up to there
so anyway he just stops talking and just
walks off
so he just starts doing the tour again
the Essex guy straight over you've dealt
with that really well then mate if he
got in my face like that I'd have just
[__] punched him and I was like right
sorry I've got someone else who's on my
side the Irish guy doesn't really
acknowledge it keeps walking but he
keeps bitching about his knee now my
sympathy for him is completely gone I'm
going up this hill yeah and me and my
Muslim wife are going to enjoy the rest
of our holidays yeah and we'll probably
make some more Muslims as well mate so
yeah think about this while you're
[__] waking up over your knee the guy
began to make a bit of a point himself
where he would now stop and actually do
a tour oh so every time the tour would
stop I'd go oh at all fantastic now
you're on your I'm on it so so you don't
piss me off like that right yeah but I'd
also make a very pointed point every
time we'd stop in the middle of nowhere
and go just to be clear is there a cash
machine around here
we get back down okay and the the tour
has sort of soured at this point because
it sounds really bad the vibe's sound
terrible no one has received a tour and
since I've raised the point onto the
rest of the group the rest of the group
has sort of gone oh yeah we haven't
really had a tour have we like we were
sort of expecting a tour here we go
halfway back down the mountain and the
guy goes right it's time to pay up to me
at this point in my head I'm weighing it
up do I really want to pay you now
pardon me you've sort of given me a
situation here where I don't really
wanna like you've not given me the tour
I was expecting and the transaction is
worth the money now this isn't worth the
money uh you you've actually been in one
of the few people who gets to experience
the tour and go
45 Euros doesn't seem like value yeah
right no not at all right you could have
done all this on your own I could have
done all of it and everyone else had
come to consensus in the group I go to a
cash machine and my card works there I
get the money out and I come back over
and while I'm counting the money out I'm
like by the way you're lucky you're
getting anything here because that was
one of the worst tours I've ever been on
and the way you spoke to me like it's
just not customer service and he goes I
don't know what you mean get back on the
bus I'm like no you spoke to me like
[__] and you were aggressive on the side
of the mountain and then you didn't give
us the rest of the tour and I'm still
paying you full price and other people
have paid you full price for this at
which point the Irish guy pipes up and
goes you don't speak for me I turn to
him and I literally go yeah I'm quite
clear about that don't worry about that
buddy you sit down all right so he sits
down which pisses his wife off so his
wife then goes well John and I was
literally like I'll deal with you later
so then another woman in the group comes
out and she goes listen I don't
I don't like conflict oh and I was like
I do feel sorry for her yeah and I was
like and I sort of looked at her and I
was like what she went clearly you're in
the wrong here just pay him the money
and we'll go back and we'll go back and
I was like oh God
now you've stuck your RN
do I reply to you and sort of go nuclear
here or not and I was like and I made
the decision not to in that moment I
think he did the right thing I did give
her a pattern work but the point is like
what did he say well we'll get to that
we're still arguing because she goes you
should let this you should let this drop
and I'm like yeah you know what maybe
bygones be bygones your money's there
enjoy it whatever he gives me
five euros back but anyway as I'm
getting back on the bus and he's sliding
the door over he's going anyway as
everyone can see on the bus I'm
absolutely right and I've not done
anything wrong here door closes like
that and I'm just at the back of the bus
like this is [__] bizarre man like
did it make you annoyed when you try to
have the last word yeah because you love
Allah of course I love the last one so
I've got no other chance to have the
last word I get off the bus at the other
end to drop me back at the hotel and he
turns to me just so you know I know the
people at the tour company and they like
me oh wow he showed weakness there that
woman pipes up again and she she says I
can't know what she says but she
basically says like I don't like
conflict and she's sort of having to go
at him but and and I'm sort of standing
there watching so I stop her and I go
sorry do you work for this tour company
and and she goes no and I don't
understand what this has to do with you
then you you don't need to be speaking
in this situation it's got nothing to do
with you she's
oh my goodness management exactly and
then the guy shut the door and they just
drove off but the whole time they drove
off he was just doing this he was just
going
so anyway I'm not tour company every day
since and I still haven't received a
refund
but what I have done is made their lives
living hell does that make you satisfied
yeah I've wasted like the other day the
guy on the line said to me you're just
wasting time here and I went yeah
and I said what you're doing is you're
missing calls that are trying to book
with you right now and the guy went yeah
so can I hang up and I went no
and we just sit on the phone and we just
sit there and I go so when's your boss
going to talk to me and he goes I don't
know but this has been going on for
almost like four or five weeks now
well I'll just call and basically just
go hey me again is there anything that
has changed in the situation as your
boss what they're gonna do there's
nobody else on the [__] Island who
want to do that job no that's the
problem so in their head they're like
he's yay [__] but he's all we've got
[__] it he was just so rude but not only
to me to everyone else oh he's an
absolute [__] and everyone was saying
look at his job they go up a hill go
down the hill right up the hill go
downhill once a week little bit of
advice right gone
from personal experience yeah there are
some people in life who you have to walk
away from and even if they think they've
won you have to remember they're stuck
in their life with them and he is stuck
in his head you have a great life
absolutely and he is stuck in his little
[__] life no but I think he has a good
life
if this guy
appreciated what he had his attitude
would not be so miserable and that was
for no reason but this is the thing when
people hit you with that attitude and in
my opinion anyway in life it's because
they're so not content with their own
lives that's why like on the tube you
see so many crazy people having these
outputs they're not really angry at each
other for something that's just happened
on the truth they're angry at their
lives that's why YouTube comments no
offense guys but they're angry you know
people aren't that bothered about some
[__] I've just said on a podcast
right they angry at their lives and I've
just literally burst the bubble like
I've said something let's take them off
but it's the entire bubble that's pissed
them off it's not me and his bubble
but it's that but why are you letting
the Mind jump so much no is this did it
warm me up it was more that in that
moment I was just I was a bit like um
I don't wanna I Don't Wanna Be I don't
want to back down from that you don't
want to be a victim yeah I didn't want
to be a victim so I didn't back down but
I didn't also want to be that guy who
ruins the tour and everyone else was
sort of coming over to me and going yeah
you know what you did the right thing
there like people weren't sort of going
[__] hell of that no you absolutely
did the right thing I did the right
thing but it was just that one the
middle-aged woman from Sweden or Denmark
or where the [__] she was from just
pissed me off and that [__]
islamophobic Irish guy those and that
made it all the more surreal I'm on the
side of a mountain with an islamophone
and a tour guide that doesn't want to
guide us who's going you need to go to a
cash machine now it's weird because as
I've gotten older I've had a lot of
things said about me in life and a lot
of um interactions with people which
haven't gone greater you know no [__]
and I've become so good at going okay
yeah like I let things go now so I'm
like don't get me wrong don't get me
wrong it was different for you because
that in-person interaction
if someone got in my face I'd still
knock them out don't get me wrong but
what I mean is is post event I'm a lot
better at just disregarding and going
hey you know what that kind has to be
miserable with themselves for the rest
of their life I get a walk off and and
concentrate on me so it's sort of become
a little playful thing that I have with
that company oh I can tell you're
enjoying that side of it it's more like
um originally I would just sort of call
them and then I'd be doing something
else but I'd just be like on
speakerphone so I'd just be getting
through the emails playing a bit of FIFA
but the point is I do the emails and
just sort of go so what's the weather
like in Madeira today and just try and
keep them on for as long as I could and
then when they would clock that I was
trying to keep them on for as long as
they could I go yeah you've just missed
a load of calls for whatever to book
whatever tour just give me my refund and
they just won't give me this refund the
the funny thing is the amount of money
you've probably spent phoning them up
will be far more than jokes on them I've
got a bolt on
the point is though never give up on a
refund I like it a lot of people out
there are going now Lawrence is the [__]
here no I think they're trying to
reframe this in the comments do you know
what I mean this is a story where sure I
don't come off well I didn't have money
but in the end the guy got paid we made
an agreement he could not let me on the
bus no they just have gone fair enough
I've not come with money that's my fault
stick to your side Andre who I call
Smelly Andre the email the email I
complained with I said a small man who
uh has a distinctive smell about him
which is not pleasant and weirdly the
woman who read the email and then caught
and I called the next day uh said it was
a very funny email okay which is a small
win because you love an audience even if
that's just one person yeah yeah I
probably find the email but another
thing that people have asked us to talk
about Tick Tock is is the place for the
most talentless people in the world some
some people are talented but the most
talentless go to Tick Tock but there's
some a couple of talented people mixed
in the biggest tick tockler in the world
doesn't speak say no more
that that proves my yeah that proves my
point no offense to the guy I'm not I
mean good good good on you I don't know
hate yeah we should try that but the
point is is that's what a [__] app this
is the talent wise you don't even have
to speak to be the biggest thing on the
app and it's kind of got to be that it's
got to be it's almost good that he
doesn't speak because that means you can
get an audience from South America you
know uh Europe yeah the point is you
know it's smart no but he's mildly
creative but I'm just saying it sounds
like an indictment it's tick tock it's a
load of [__] so anyway they've got this
51 year old guy in there whatever he is
this poor man right and I have been
watching fighting for as long as I can
remember now and hit the weigh-in this
old man he looked in good shape for an
old man got to give him credit you
really and you know he's trying to
defend his daughter and we've got a he
isn't no Izzy well uh they're cashing in
on a drama as well there's a there's a
lot of that is all going on and look
we're talking about them so something
was achieved will they regret that in a
way though I don't know but you know his
sense challenge he's since challenged
Greg Paul sorry is Greg Paul actually
going to fight him where is he Greg Paul
here we go listen Simple Simon I
understand why you got the simple part
in there
uh I'll fight you
but you know look
you see that yeah he's done I think my
arm is bigger than your calf here's the
deal I'll fight you bare knuckle or MMA
send me the contract so you can quit
your [__] lion and your daughter
cannot be in the arena because I don't
want her to see you get the [__] beat on
you you scrawny little [__] smile
here's the thing right Greg Paul can
speak all this [__] Chris he's now a
multi-millionaire based on both of us
but this is the thing Greg Paul um he's
the kind of guy who he always seems to
be like chopping wood and stuff
absolutely
not a motor and like yeah yeah look I
get this Simon fellas thought you know
what I'll have another one because it
was a [__] performance okay it's simple
but the people organizing this event too
let that young kid beat the living [__]
out of that old man this is why people
die in the ring though like this this is
gonna be funny no honestly honestly I I
walk I I just remember going
[__] you know I do remember and that kid
didn't even have technique or anything
he was just leathering him like beating
the [__] out of yeah it was basically I
think whoever landed first in that fight
and landed a big no but I sort of
stunned him no I don't know I don't know
if that was the case because it the
weigh-in I've seen hundreds thousands of
weigh-ins this old man God bless him
when he got up on stage and he looked in
the this kid's eyes and I seen the life
drain out of this man and he was like oh
[__] I'm getting [__] up tomorrow the
reality oh he looked terrified and the
fact that he's still got in the ring
anyway I got respect for you bro like
fair enough you're doing this for you or
whatever what does this mean for you
I've never seen someone more scared and
still get in the ring like I we've seen
lots of last minute pull outs in the UFC
and and chill Sonnen has gone in depth
and said like there's a lot of people
who just [__] bottle it you know like
really oh yeah because it overcomes you
sometimes you're like [__] this you know
Donald Cerrone he's talked about it I
was in there with McGregor I thought
what the [__] am I doing in here well I
don't want to be here so credit to him
but maybe not Greg Paul bro like that
maybe not anyone he's just gonna have
big money how about just
just stop he's just having to capitalize
isn't he because he knows if I ride this
I can make the most money I'll make out
of this scenario
you're not a fighter though this is the
thing even Fighters like people are
questioning right now like director Zora
like Derek chisora is like the toughest
[__] in boxing basically and
people are like you know should we
retire now like I mean how many of these
fights can he handle you know he's too
tough for his own good but he's a pro
fighter in his 40s this guy is just a
normal guy in his 50s normal there's a
lot of men in their 50s who still think
they still think they're 20 and I get it
right but even me right I'm 35 years old
I can feel I can feel I I in I did a
heavy bench press the other day I I got
up afterwards I was like [__] me that's
harder than it used to be like right you
know what I mean like
25 to 35 is a difference 50 don't think
for one second you could take punches at
50 anymore like you will get like people
like even John fury like people like
them like it's a dangerous game to be
playing when you get older because
you're so much easier hurt so it's funny
you mentioned John because I was kind of
going to bring John into John's a
unicorn John's probably the toughest man
alive and probably will always be one of
the toughest literally yeah he's the guy
who they break in and then all of a
sudden John kills them you know that
time though that John said
um I will [__] your girlfriend in front
of you or whatever he said tommywood
Tommy do it like a dog right now with
the tick tock thing is that what
happened there because he defended his
daughter's
um what honor and he lost so does the
guy now have sex with his daughter like
how does that work his daughter also
fought on the event and she was a Savage
she's
tough right was she the one who was
meant to fight Astrid yeah yeah but she
didn't end up fighting or whatever but
this this blonde girl I mean I'm so
clueless but she beat the [__] out of
some girl and I was like wow I don't
know like you have that like stallion
energy about you right like you kill
kill a woman yeah she didn't look that
way in the Press but then so why did she
need it would have been better if she'd
fought the guy this whole thing is
[__] mental what sort of concerns me
a little bit now someone said this the
other day like they were like look it
won't be the direct influence of social
media but it would be the kind of things
that make you think in a certain way
it's just the abundance of sexual and
aggressive content on social media that
just makes me feel a bit uncomfortable
at this point like so I was looking at
Snapchat the other day right and I might
sound a bit off because of this if you
scroll through this page I love I've
never really used Snapchat and I'd love
to work with them just to diversify the
content it's all
naked women look at that and I've not
even clicked on any of these sex cells
Lawrence and if you if you want any
proof of that if you go on Instagram or
something like that and we're talking
about
you know the gym and you see very tight
leggings and people doing a lot of
exercises that are not bomb related
maybe they're doing their back
you will see the ass first front row and
Center more than anything and the camera
is you people can be doing their triceps
still doing cameras on the horse you
know people know what they're doing
you're not at framing maybe people know
what they're doing you know what I mean
and and by all means if you want to show
off your butt show off your butt but but
let's not that's not like that's not
happening I don't think it gives anyone
the right to comment anything vulgar in
the comments but I also think you should
not be shocked and appalled when your
ass is front row and Center on almost
every video and you get men commenting
about it because it's right [__]
there you can't play a dumb so I stop
acting like you're shocked by this
that's what we found quite interesting
when we did the sort of um the pregnancy
reveal was a lot of people suddenly felt
that they were able to say to me I'm
surprised that you had that in you I
thought that your thought was very
tasteful no no what I mean is that I was
like they a lot of people I think uh saw
me as someone who's not very sexual so
they were like oh we weren't really we
didn't know that you were capable of
impregnating someone but then we flew
they were like oh I like pregnant women
blah blah they thought even that for
them was a come on they were like oh
well she's revealed her body so now I
can say whatever I want and I found that
quite strange but I feel like there's
there's a scale I think there's no phone
well what they're doing yeah most people
are trying like obviously there's the
cancer of social media which is just
people are gonna abuse you for anything
you do and a few short the slightest bit
of skin a man is going to ask you for
pictures of your feet and all of that
right they're the freaks we know that
they're out there I've got them
everyone's got them you know I get told
to commit suicide on a [__] weekly
basis so I thought you meant everyone
has feet you know or they want pictures
of my feet in which case 20 quid ago
they're the extreme and I'm not talking
about women should accept that by any
stretch of the imagination I just mean
that you know lesser comments but that
are still pervy
um I I I'm not saying anyone should
accept them but to to act as if they are
a shock in some way and be appalled by
it when you're presenting your ass in
such a way first presenting is just
enough and and there's some genuine
workout tricks out there and men out
there who are just training putting
their footage out there and not asking
for any extra attention and not
necessarily posing in a certain way
right but a lot of people read can't
keep his [__] shirt on for two no I
never I wouldn't keep my [__] show
and if I look like [__] me too
um but what I'm saying is a lot of women
specifically will be pausing in as
little as possible and
they take the rough with the smooth they
they are aware I'm gonna get two million
followers if I do this so therefore if
I'm going to do it I'm going to cash in
and yeah I'll accept a few of those uh
crappy comments because I know it's
worth what I'm what I'm doing in the
long run but it's the ones who act like
oh how do I'm shocked by it inside
you've got your [__] you know your
yeah there's a bit we're animals here
you know like you know we're not
completely robotic like men are gonna
notice this stuff that's what's
generating your following you can't have
the two million without one million
people hate following you or a certain
amount of them following you for the sex
fact that you've that you've actually
grown that of so just let I I just don't
like people bullshitting themselves that
people are interested in their
inspirational comments underneath a
picture of their ass where the you know
or are you well done I can understand I
get frustrated by the fact that we're
all not acknowledging the reality of the
gym industry for example or you know sex
cells so let's not act like that isn't a
big factor in what this big movement is
sure or at least yeah and then there are
other nuances to that like for instance
I know it might be that initially the
sexy picture gets you to click on the
item to buy the item but actually the
item might also be functional dumb right
so you want to know within this person
let's say this fictional person who has
a big booty who's doing a squat she also
might have some cool [__] to say she
might do good workout videos she might
help other women to be inspired and
there might be a hell of a lot of good
that she can do with that but that
charity I'm also just saying like if she
uses certain tools to get to that point
right then just don't be shocked that
there's a hint of negativity that comes
with it so you're saying there's like a
downside to all there's a downtight to
everything and some people just want to
act like that should never be a part of
life and it's like
I I agree in in an ideal Society yes but
like a lot of Instagram profiles and a
lot of social media is just full of yeah
let's pretend uh you're looking at my
gym workout when really this is all
about the ass crack sure come on this is
a [__] I'm sick of [__] people
hiding their head in the sand like this
ain't [__] reality here we all know
what's happening and men too by the way
oh yeah men want to be admired too and
there's there's nothing wrong with women
want to be admired all men want to be
admired it's the double standards it's
their unrealistic expectations uh people
wanting this to be [__] Disneyland
but on the other side some people also
want those comments they want to
encourage other people to comment they
want to create a bit of a community a
positivity a positivity and that's cool
but with positivity there's balance in
life yeah for every nice person you meet
you meet an [__] probably you know
like and it's just there were 12 people
in the tour and the tour guide was the
[__] we get it this is why I never
engage on Twitter this is why I never go
back and forth with people on social
media because I'm like what [__]
difference in my life does any of this
[__] make anymore like the saddest thing
is is I get why like if I was to engage
with every single person who says
anything about me it would be better for
views and look when I go off it I could
I can make something entertaining [__]
happen you know people [__] other
things I come out with but I'm growing
as a person and I don't want to continue
just wasting time bickering with it's
all about ego it's all about ego and I
can I'm now in control of my ego to a
level and not that I don't have an ego
but I'm in control of it where I can go
is this really more important than the
[__] I really care about absolutely
because that's what's going to take away
from and that you know what I mean like
it's not so your ego can engage in
different moments so in a weak moment it
might still engage my ego gets me up in
the morning to work hard to be a better
version of myself and into like and want
to prove to me that I can can make
better videos make better podcasts do
good interviews and even lately I've
been looking at my interviews going no
I feel like I need to switch it up a bit
and be a bit more just something you
know I'm always thinking about stuff
like that but but my ego isn't worrying
about what other people are doing and I
think that's the worst thing is because
they say um comparison is the thief of
joy and it is so [__] true and I feel
like a lot of people have come at me in
the past because maybe they compared
yeah or or I feel like coming at someone
with a big audience always has paid off
in the past but for me I I'm I just sort
of sit there and I just think what the
[__] are you doing like you know what I
mean like I'm quite um I'm an overall of
that YouTube [__] now beefs and crap
like that I'm so bored like you know
someone wants to get in my face I'll
quite happily fight anyone but it's this
internet [__] is not deep people who who
are living in the internet who are so
like this is my identity this is who I
really am and I kind of like the fact
that I had like a true Geordie because
it really helps me sort of in my head go
I'm on camera all right this is me being
me but also I'm leaving that afterwards
I can be a bit more like all right yeah
that's they they think they know who I
am but if they're new who I really am if
people knew my life story like my real
full life story I think a lot of people
would look at me so differently they'd
be like [__] me you got through all of
that to get here right what am I having
to go at you for I should be celebrating
them or yeah or at least like
empathizing or sharing yeah no one would
say [__] about me if they knew all of
the ins and outs because it's been rough
to get to where I've got right I'm
content with uh with knowing that and
going you did well bro and what anyone
else says after that is like I take it
all with like good or bad yeah okay
thanks yeah and but I guess what I'm
concerned about is that kind of I guess
the tick-tockiness of things maybe where
you can't I don't know I'm not sure how
often you can really get into the
reality of stuff in a short video you
can't it that Tick-Tock and Vine and all
of these things of the past it they're
the worst bit of the internet in my
opinion it's like the distraction it's
the fast food of the Internet it's quick
and just like fast food it's not good
for you it's it's not too much it's not
got generally it's it's mildly
entertaining for that minute but it
ain't gonna it ain't gonna really
fulfill you with the information and the
knowledge that's going to actually
change your life and make you a better
person you might learn a cool dance you
might find something funny but like
to me like when I think of good content
I am you know I've been watching Emma
Kenny's YouTube channel she does like
two-hour breakdowns of like
um murders that have happened or or but
it's it's this in Insight that I get
from her of the psychological insight of
how people spiral from being from their
upbringing right at the point where
they're absolutely the most horrible
thing it makes you understand so much
about people things like that I grow
from that I learned from that
it's fast food well it's also
interesting about Tick Tock because you
are back to back you have something that
makes you happy something that makes you
sad something makes you horny something
makes you like there's like you can be
scrolling through a feed and it'll give
you 10 different things that want to
elicit ten different emotions but it's
all very primitive emotions yeah that is
a roller coaster for people to go
through yeah especially and that's why
that we're creating a generation of
people who are like ADHD or at least
they're told they're ADHD
but right but our attention spans are
dwindling away rapidly I remember when
we met uh will uh will only he couldn't
sit through a movie because he was so
used to YouTube sure like when we were
hanging out and he would be good now
though do you know no but that's not a
criticism I will I'm talking about that
was will then I'm talking about that was
Will from YouTube yeah Tick Tock how are
you going to keep people's interests on
a movie now that everyone's sitting
watching that [__] will do yeah I guess
that's what you and I grew up like
watching long-form documentaries
long-form movies The God for that's
three and a half [__] hours long for
Christ's sakes like things that have
changed my life that I've watched
religiously because I've got so much
from them it's just instant
gratification and that is never that's
not that's not how you build a life for
yourself it's how you waste time yeah it
really is and that's what Tick Tock is
in my opinion yeah I'm not saying it
isn't a powerful tool and it can't be
used for good occasionally but generally
it's [__] yeah generally you'll
you'll find that you won't particularly
get much from these things that you're
watching or you'll never act on it or
whatever yeah it is and most of the time
it is just facile you know you're
watching it that was funny
sometimes quite Macho or sometimes quite
sort of undermining of everything else
that's going on at that point and quite
Trend driven I mean it's completely
Trend driven and and people can game
that and it can
it can falsely give them a status in
history that they don't necessarily
deserve I said to Geo I was like um
how's this kid saying he's gonna make
this Fella's daughter suck his dick
right on the boxing thing I was like how
is he the biggest thing on Tick Tock and
he was like it was a tick tock rewards
that behavior of like if you're a
lunatic right people are watching you
right and I was like Wow and I get that
like there are probably people who use
tick tock on a daily basis who know how
to get the best out of it and all those
kind of things I'm not necessarily
talking about those kind of people I'm
not talking about all tick-tockers but
you know come on no there's a lot out
there that's trash I also just think
like very often if you think you're
above it or you think you're smarter
than it or you think like you've gained
it then the likelihood is you're
probably most
vulnerable to it it's the same people
who say to like hypnosis and oh you can
never hypnotize me I guarantee you those
people are the most hypnotizable people
I I think you're and Tick Tock is doing
that on a mass scale right it's like
there's a theory that uh China are using
Tick Tock in a totally different way
than we are where they're using it to
educate the kids right and that they're
deliberately making our content Trend
that's the dumbest [__] possible and
everything I'm seeing verifies that yeah
exactly right yeah but that's kind of my
point is like I think at the moment I'd
be interested to know what the audience
think about that is just like where'd
you get where you know what gives you
something to kind of grasp on to what is
your thing that makes you feel like okay
I understand where life is going yeah or
I understand where the world is going
because that can't be a pleasant world
to grow up in one last thing that people
uh wanted us to comment on
um party the Buddy friend of the show uh
we had them before we got famous an
amazing speech you gave after his fight
about a friend of his who committed
suicide and it was like I think it was
the best horse fight speech in terms of
most powerful um in UFC history for sure
yeah this is the modest thing is is like
people compare Paddy to Conor McGregor
because he's like the fastest rising
star since McGregor he's the first
fighter I have seen where he wasn't the
main eventer but he was the main event
yeah since McGregor and this isn't a
slate on McGregor or well I mean maybe
it is in in a way in terms of how he's
misused his Fame but what Paddy did uh
on that
on that night surpassed anything Conor
McGregor's ever done in his career ever
like that is so powerful what he did
there was
it connected with so many people it went
like viral and viral and viral like it
was so people want us to talk about how
he said he said I'd rather have my
friend crying on my shoulder than going
to his funeral and I think that
connected it struck up with a lot of
people it was so from the Heart In the
Heat of the Moment it was not planned it
was not
and to have someone who is a cage
fighter who's tough as Nails saying that
and speaking so
vulnerably tears in his eyes
um and then afterwards him sobbing on
the cage floors You'll Never Walk Alone
please it was like even now just talking
about it
goosebumps you know what I mean it was
like we had this guy in the studio
before this whole thing sort of he
before he was even signed with the UFC
and him sort of saying I'm going to take
over and there was a no lie there was a
hint of me that I thought yeah I mean
you've got a lot of the talents and
people are going to connect with you but
like to imagine that he would take over
to this level and become this size of a
star in this short spell of time is
blowing my [__] mind like in many
ways he was primed like he had a whole
city behind him he had the perfect
background he's got a good style for
that as well so I think it's a perfect
kind of I mean he's very unique looking
he's very you know you'll know that guy
at the Paddy wigs and all of that the
wigs but but it's the skill set like I
mean he's an elite level fighter but
like how good he is is sort of yet to be
seen but he's very good and what I love
is he's capitalizing now so it's not
about I'm you know it's not just about
him being great fighter it's actually
just about him connecting with people
and having a relationship that's the
difference yeah and I think that I guess
that's what kind of candy did in terms
of Ireland that was for you and that
sort of thing but Paddy is built
different to him he's a he's a he's a
real people person yeah you know like
he's all about his community and giving
back the his and his friends and his
family and all of that and I'm not
saying that there's none of that and you
know I don't want to talk about kind of
uh too much because I'm sure Connor's
given plenty back as well I'm sure he
has but Conor's alienated his whole fan
base by acting like a big weirdo and now
me included like I don't root for him in
a fight I don't give a [__] if he wins
or loses is he putting together McGregor
Mayweather too no that's not happening
no DNS canceled that he said that's not
happening but he's making a comeback I
think it's a pointless exercise because
the guys um basically been on holiday
for the best part of six years you saw
him stamp on that guy's hat the other
day of course that was a big because the
guy throw throws a Connor on his
birthday bash and Ibiza and Conor was
like oh and he throws on the floor and
he's like
stamps stamps on it in such an
aggressive way and I'm like bro like
you're an accident because at one point
I think who are you man like you've got
a [__] Lamborghini Yacht for [__]
sake what do you care about a hat being
thrown at you yeah and it was thrown
softly I wasn't even like it was a hats
it was just like like you know what I
mean it wasn't anything like all and I'm
like what are you on what are you doing
you know you're supposed to be a
world-class fighter only stamping on
someone's heart as if like
oh like isn't that kind of a mental
health problem in itself though he's got
problems but yeah but this is different
way I would just urge party and to to
just stick with where he's lucky he's
got Molly and people like that around
yeah I mean he seems quite grounded
there's a lot of grounded the realest
one yeah and I know there's always those
people who always go um you know oh
Patty had some tweets back in the day or
whatever like this is people want to try
and get him down or whatever what he is
saying and doing now I fully think I
stand behind I think what he's saying
and being as a figure like a role model
I think is fantastic I feel like so many
men immediately would have went yeah
yeah you'd almost you could feel people
reaching for their phone and going it
was [__] attack yeah it's very rare I
see something happen and I'm like oh
[__] hell you've just you've spoken
and the world is listening here right
and that's so rare because
of all of the the stars in boxing and
fighting
it very rarely does that ever happen
like I can't think of many times where
a fighter has had the world in the palm
of his hand McGregor obviously being one
of them and Paddy off of three fights
having that level of attention and and
off part of this is off the back of
Connor because he's propelled the UFC
into a way he has similar backgrounds in
that sense too I work in class kids but
but the point is is so much bigger now
because of Conor and other stars that
when Paddy spoke it went further after a
shorter amount of time of him being in
the UFC but it's because it's the
continent yeah it's what you said I just
feel like I hope he he follows that road
it doesn't get sidetracked by the
boozing and the partying and the
[__] and the you know I know he's
got to settle life with his woman and
all of that and it's just like
Don't Lose Yourself now kid like you've
got everything where it needs to be just
focus on the Arts you know what I mean
McGregor has also built up to a point
where like it was unattainable that any
human being could be almost Conor
McGregor so that the standards for Conor
were so high right Paddy has come out
the gate quite fallible and he was
clearly a bit rough around the edges in
a different way to the way that McGregor
was he had a bit he's got a bit more of
a kind of Shaggy look to him where it's
maybe a bit more relatable well I think
I think Paddy rates himself
but he doesn't love himself right the
way Connor did yeah and then don't get
me wrong there was a there was a
Razzmatazz and a Showmanship that is you
know it's it you know it's so [__]
entertaining I can't take that away from
the guy even though I dislike him now
there's a like ability there that is
different the groundedness and I just
hope he keeps a hold of that no matter
what and I think in Liverpool it's it's
gonna happen yeah weirdly I think like
there's a lot I don't know Liverpool
does have a bit of a um a knack for kind
of making people who can stay quite
grounded like Stephen Stephen Gerrard uh
although you know obviously Gerard had
his own thing where he slapped a DJ or
something but apart from that but people
like Robbie Fowler and that like foul
losing I've interviewed Robbie Fowler
not long ago and he was so aware of
being liver puddling like there's just
something about if you're aware of where
you come from and who you represent and
who you are there's almost a bit of a
wait on you to be that and there were
times where I think Conor maybe forgot a
little bit about that or felt like well
I've risen above that oh he 100 is acted
like he's he's left that now and he's
above it and um in my opinion and I
think that's why if you mention McGregor
to an Irish person
yeah they're like not that guy right
like he's not he's lost before he's lost
the people one million percent because
of the umpteen dumb [__] things he's
done and
how in love with himself he became hence
the stamping on the hat as if it's a
[__] person do you know another thing
I think is actually taking a back seat
is I've not actually heard that much
about men's or just in peoples in
general but specifically men's mental
health recently like it was really of
the moment at one point everyone was
talking about the mental health everyone
was talking and sharing those kind of
things and part of it has almost been it
became a tool for oh yeah I've had
mental health problems too and it's like
no but you're feeling down every now and
then that's different to what people are
actually but do you know what I mean
yeah but the thing I think really
stamped it out was covered yeah because
what couldn't be acknowledged by a lot
of governments and I'm not saying this
from a conspiracy angle no it's a
reality angle what couldn't be
acknowledged by a lot of governments was
the mental impact that all of these
different things were going to have a
the worry about a pandemic you know you
worry about your family your dad your
mum your wife I don't think the world
has ever been more mentally stressed out
right in my existence at that moment and
I don't
really feel like a government at any
point has kind of addressed hey we're in
this together in a sense like ironic
yeah I get that and that's what I'm
saying like because we're not and to add
to that they've almost like pushed it
down so it's like hey should we look at
Men's mental health no we'll push that
one in a couple years time when the
suicides rate has gone down or when this
is a million percent there's no doubt my
mind the suicide rate's gone through the
roof because of what what went on
because people were communicating like
the amount of like physical interaction
that people lost out on that changes how
you feel yeah and also just being alone
being with possibly an abusive partner
being with someone who you don't want to
be within a relationship all these
different kind of things stopped
people's lives Paddy spoke to those
people you real walk in that absolutely
yeah and then afterwards you know the
the tourists like it sort of works but
like those two things go hand in hand
and no one's saying [__] conservatism
although some people are what they're
saying is [__] these people who clearly
don't care about us or clearly have a
party when we're on
to add to that we've had so many times
where there have been you know
government people who have had a moment
they've been given a microphone that's
been put in front of them not after
fighting in a cage by the way after
having a private car to a studio and
they've gone say something to the people
and they've just gone well I think the
important thing we've got to remember
here is the economy's got to recover
Paddy spoke to more people in that short
speech after being punched in the face
and being like you know all these
different things scrap yeah in a proper
scrap with a guy who by the way was
probably the best fighter he's faced so
far are those guys absolutely yeah and
then he said that more people listen to
that than anything Boris Johnson said he
found out about his friend dying the day
before the fight absolutely and he had
to keep it together and he had a job to
do and that's what being a man is about
in many respects is maturity you you
have to take on board all this [__]
that you're going through in life
sometimes that's what builds strengths
in people if there's one thing that I
feel bulletproof from in my life right
now it's normal I've overcome so for him
to do that in his life and to build a
handle that moment and then break down
in front of the world it was
probably the most powerful thing I've
seen in MMA and you know in boxing MMA
all of it it's it doesn't
um maybe people might think a bit going
overboard there but like
no this is real and and I think some
people in the fight game they use Mental
Health as a way of you know it's good
marketing it is it is and and I think
that there's a lot of people in the
influencers and all of that oh mental
health mental health you can just sort
of feel the reality from the bullshiters
and that was the realest [__] ever that
Paddy said that moment and that's why I
connected so well it was also partly
because it wasn't it wasn't about him
really oh no it was actually about
someone else and very often I think
you know it's you know most people they
don't want to co-op someone else's
mental health but he was speaking about
something that impacted him and there
were so many people that could relate to
that you know it's quite impersonal to
hear someone go my mental Health's not
been good recently because that people
sort of go yeah yeah everyone's mental
health no you're right I I genuinely
think you save lives and I know that's
such a like um
that that would have saved lives there's
just not a doubt in my mind
it could be one life do you and it could
be a hundred but there's a real issue
right now I think in Britain where
people don't feel particularly hopeful
and I'd imagine that goes outside
especially young men and that's kind of
what
I mean we mentioned Jordan Peterson
earlier in the podcast when he talks
about young men and how disillusioned
they feel and that's one of the things I
do think he gets right occasionally is
like I think men aren't getting a great
uh rub of it in society at the moment
and that's not to say women are
just like men feel a bit forgotten and
like
it's uh I have a lot of them reaching
out to me uh you know and
just hopeless so that's that's the
feeling and the mood is so like we can't
change our lives anymore like the the
ladder to grow from being a middle class
kid or not a class kid or a working
class kid get up get up in life and make
something yourself it feels like the
ladder has been pulled up from these for
these kids and they just and Paddy is is
a is a one-off he's an exception I am a
one-off you know I'm the lucky one who
but there's not it doesn't happen Jeremy
and they feel like [__] me I've got a
life of this [__] right you know what I
mean like and then you're told there's
an impending recession or what they call
like a financial crisis or any of these
kind of things it doesn't leave you
feeling
particularly hopeful should we say well
and I get it like people you've got to
deal with the reality of this most
people doing well in in in the upper
echelons it's Daddy's Money situations
it's been born into it you know what I
mean it's and in the 60s and 70s and 80s
there was so much more room to grow from
being lower class middle class to get up
and if you had that motivation that
drive and that intelligence you could
make a a million that would be a cell
you don't do whatever you want you feel
that way yeah so those are just shutting
now and I think that that's part of it
as well so yeah um there was a little
study about um antidepressants that I
did want to also touch on uh saying that
you know there's there's a debate there
whether serotonin levels are actually
linked with depression and stuff like
that and I just thought a study has
found this it doesn't necessarily mean
the study is bang on you know what I
mean things can be because uh and I'm
not saying that it is wrong or right or
whatever but all I can say is um and
people ask me this every now and then so
I might as well talk about but my
medication has changed my life like
right I'm on
certainly which is uh a common
antidepressant and I think even you can
tell like in the year that I've been on
it around about a year my depression and
my self-control and and all of that and
like my outbursts and things that I used
to struggle with calm right down
everything and and it hasn't turned me
into somewhere I wasn't or it's just
sorted out those nosedives of of feeling
like you want to kill yourself or
um
impending doom or anxiety it don't get
me wrong it doesn't make life perfect
and and you know I I'm not on a high
dose but uh particularly but I feel like
um it just enabled me to manage life in
a way that isn't as Kamikaze as what it
used to feel right
um yeah and of course you know post-raq
stress disorder which I've had enough of
um in my life it's really helped me cope
with that so well I've seen that and I
thought you know what I've got a
platformer I want to tell my side of
what I feel about antidepressants and I
I genuinely feel like they've
potentially saved my life really because
I was spiraling going down the wrong
road how did you feel about them before
you started taking them terrified right
so that's what I was wondering yeah I
was worried because obviously when you
live in your own head and you're a
thinker and you're an overthinker you
worry that they're going to turn you
into some sort of like zombie or role
like it's some sort of like mental
vasectomy or something like that in a
way oh yeah I I was worried that things
like my career creativity would be a
fact that I would be affected in my
decision making and I would change who
it it really hasn't all all it's done is
stop the catastrophe feeling you know
like that Kamikaze feeling of oh
everything's [__] I should just kill
myself you know all those sort of you
know and don't get me wrong every now
and then something Creeps in but it is
so much more manageable and it just
feels like this is what I should have
been like
right this is normal so it allows you to
correct yeah you know before I was
thinking about suicide on a very regular
basis now I don't that's normal yeah
this is a good thing and some people
need antidepressants I'm one of them
what's your uh like you don't have to
have a road map like a ready-made answer
but like what is your roadmap with that
is that something you now feel
you will just you've just accepted it
and you feel very comfortable with
antidepressants yeah I'd personally be
comfortable I had taken them for the
rest of my life same though so I'm on
right now I feel like it gives me a
really
um
leveled out feeling of of life and that
when bad things happen I feel bad when
good things happen I feel good it's like
before when bad things will happen
I I just think what's the [__] point
right you fall off the deep end yeah and
combined with a rough life at times like
there definitely there was reasons for
me being feeling exhausted uh but yeah
it's it's been amazing for me it's also
interesting because obviously
antidepressants don't stop bad things
from happening yeah it helps you to deal
with the bad things that's all I'm
saying and that's kind of the point is
it's it's not something that goes
everything's fine now yeah it's kind of
a it gives it gives you the space to
make the tools to make everything but
some people just don't realize that like
when you go through [__] your brain is
no different to your leg like in that if
if you have multiple issues injuries to
your leg it ain't going to be as good as
it was before and and this is the way I
feel about it I could I'm not backing
this up with any science I could be
wrong but it was the way it was
explained to me by a doctor who said you
know you've been through a lot of trauma
your serotonin levels may be you know
out of whack because of what you've been
through and I'm not even within three
days of taking the first tablet I was
like [__] me I feel different I remember
you saying that like and and the doctor
was like oh I'll take a month and I was
like I'm telling you now
when you're as low as I've been you feel
a difference immediately and I'm feeling
the difference and then uh I had to
boost the the amount up a little bit if
anything now I'd I'd be worried about
coming off them because I feel so stable
and right good you know I don't feel I'm
not walking around all Airy fairy you
know what I mean you're not like that's
the worry isn't it yeah I think I think
they sort of just like maybe um you know
what maybe some people will have that
reaction to certain medication and
that's why different medications are
made for different people's cases right
I've heard people have adverse reactions
to antidepressants sometimes and I think
that everyone needs to treat everything
individually not everyone will get the
same uh impact as I got you were lucky
to hit first time essentially and sort
of go oh right yeah this is good for me
yeah thank God and um but this is the
thing is people people take all sorts
for all sorts and then they worry about
something for their mind but then then
there's a lot of people who who and I
also agree with this I scientifically
like chemically I really feel like I
needed them not just because I had a bad
breakup or something you know and I
think some people go on antidepressants
unnecessarily so and that's where you
really need to Define is this a bad week
bad month rough year
or is this a chemical issue like you
don't
I think that you know for me it was a
last resort it was if I don't [__]
get something I'm gonna [__] kill
myself yeah right and I really amend it
and I really felt it in my head and I
was desperate and I just rang the doctor
and I was like
I'm telling you I've been through a lot
this is needed here so I think that's
why you take them it shouldn't I'm not
saying a complete Last Resort I don't
think I should have left it as long as I
did
and maybe therapy and other things are a
go-to beforehand before you just say it
gives the drugs but like I'm saying
there are too many people also on the
other side I left it too long and
there's too many people jumping the gun
yeah you know and there's got to be a
middle ground yeah and essentially like
it isn't an exact science you can't
really no it's trial and error yeah
because a lot of mental weirdly like you
know if you see someone limping down the
street and their legs snapped in half
you go you should go to a hospital but
when someone's walking down the street
depressed you're like they might be
hungover they might be whatever like and
maybe you might see certain things in
certain friends but these things also
happen slowly like something terrible
might happen and you don't see the
impact on someone mentally immediately
or they'll go well I'm just having a
hard time or whatever
so I guess that's where the talking
thing that Paddy said sort of helps you
figure that out you figure that out yeah
because that's my point because if your
life is actually pretty decent and
you're feeling suicidal then there's a
problem and that's where I was sort of
realizing like you know my life's better
than a lot of people's lives why do I
feel like this people like like me and
you know I've got this YouTube thing
people watch me people watch that's the
point that's the main thing [__] keep
the money coming even the doctor is
going delusional yeah people like me Doc
sure they do yeah I've read the comments
yeah exactly um listen I'm in the twitch
comments yeah absolutely so yeah I just
wanted to have a little bit on that
after the party thing because uh it
people are talking about it again and
and thank God so well well done Paddy uh
shout out to uh the big lad and uh
hopefully we'll get him back on the Pod
to discuss his journey to superstardom
without a fee it's gonna be a sticking
point Brian we actually paid for him
last time yeah I don't think he needs
the money anymore not huge you know it's
it's funny because next time I connect
I'll be like I suppose the prices have
gone up now
his phone number do you think I'd text
him and see if he's still got the same
number I don't know but it's quite
humble he was sort of like oh if you
don't mind I'll get the train and I'll
I'll go here and do this thanks a lot
this is the funny thing is and
I remember him bringing his girlfriend
yeah down to London being like take her
off for the weekend you know and um
ironically had a pizza afterwards
because he [__] loves the pizza yeah
um I remember the little list of things
but like it's just so great to see how
in such a short space time he's took off
like a [__] rocket yeah that was uh
the podcast for this week uh don't
forget to click on our sponsors to
support the podcast big thank you to
them big time you do you a lot for
watching as always appreciate this hit
the like button subscribe and we'll see
us on the next one